now joining us from monday morning
quarterback albert brier to talk all
things nfl and
let's start today with tb12 visiting the
white house
cracking jokes with joe biden any
thoughts on uh tom brady who looks
fantastic
out there in the dc sun uh what are your
thoughts on the offseason tom brady's
having in his sort of
state of mind as he heads into defending
his super bowl championship albert
for a number of different reasons you
know there's the injury of course but
also
you know i think leaving a place that he
was in for 20 years
learning new teammates learning a new
system learning new coaching staff
um and now i mean like
you know i i feel like the idea that
he's gonna prove anything is gone
right like so i think he's in a really
good place where
he can just go out and play football and
i'm telling you like i i felt this way
all along like
um you know i know some people think
that you know maybe he'd be seeking some
sort of fairy tale ending to his career
or whatever
the guy just loves to play football he
loves to compete and i think
um you know the fact that you know the
story now
is solely that tom brady going back to
defend the championship and
um you know and and and getting to go
out there and compete for another year
has him in a really really good place um
again like i think a lot of the
storylines of last year you know now a
lot of those have melted away
well the storyline albert going into
this season i think would be
can tom brady repeat can the buccaneers
go back to back
does he have one more left in him but
that doesn't seem to be
on everybody's top of mind here in july
as we head into camp next
week it's all about aaron rodgers and
it's all about his status with the green
bay packers
report coming out turning down an offer
to become the highest paid player in the
nfl
what does that say about his future in
green bay and where do you see him
playing football
next year i mean quite honestly i don't
think it tells the same thing we didn't
already know
um you know the packers were out there i
talked to brian good who comes to gm
for the packers right before the draft
um or right after the draft
about it and um you know like they the
packers have never had an issue with the
idea that
they might have to adjust aaron rodgers
contract
um you know because he you know played
an mvp level last year actually won the
award and
um you know and and and the market has
moved in his position significantly and
so
yeah i i don't think the contract was
ever
the issue here um i think the issue was
communication i think the issue was the
approach the team's taking i think the
issue is
what aaron rodgers wants um the last few
years of his career
i don't think it was ever money now i
mean
you know would it help at the end of the
day um if the packers
showed commitment to aaron rodgers
monetarily and
showed you're our guy and we're not
pulling the rug out from underneath you
um and going to jordan love prematurely
um
in you know what they put in front of
him contractually yeah that would help
but yeah i don't think that that's the
money again that's about
you know the commitment to rogers and
where the organization is going to be
and how the organization's going to
operate over the next couple of years
albert brewer joins the show senior nfl
reporter for the monday morning
quarterback ben line's in for rich the
rich eisen show
but albert it would seem to me that if
aaron were solely focused on winning and
wanting to find the best situation that
gave him a chance to go to another super
bowl it would be in green bay
where he was a half away at home last
year from going to play for another
lombardi
but if it's not about money it's not
about winning
what is he asking for what does he want
well so i think what started this was
the communication issue and the fact
that he found out about
you know jordan love and his interest in
jordan love while they were on the clock
like
i think that you know i think that
basically sounded the alarm for him you
know made him feel like right or wrong
that he was on the clock at the
quarterback of the packers
um you know and i think that there's a
sort of undercurrent of that
um in their relationship since and so
i think it's you know the relationship
between rogers and the front office i
don't think it's so much the coaches but
the relationship between
rogers and the front office was strained
by that you know and then i think the
other piece of it
um and i think that this goes for a lot
of the quarterback movement over
here um is what happened in tamil
and you know it's not just that tom
brady got an operation built around him
it's not just that the bucks are
building on his timetable and with
um you know a certain sense of urgency
is that it worked
you know it's that like i think for guys
that were knocked out of the playoffs
last year
at that position that are older they're
looking at it and they're saying give me
some of that
and you know i i think not only do they
want it because
they want to have organizations centered
around them
um but i think they also want it because
they know that's what they're up against
and having to get past the buccaneers
the next couple of years
and so i think for you russell wilson
for your aaron rodgers for even a
matthew stafford
part of the reason there was cage
rattling this year at the quarterback
position
is because of uh you know what we're
seeing
and where the sport may be going now and
you can call the lebronization of the
sport
um if you want and i would argue that
darren rodgers in
great situation right now in green bay
um to go and win a championship
you know but i can also see where other
quarterbacks want what brady has and
feel like they might have a tough time
competing with an organization that's
operating on the sort of
short time table that the bucks are
operating on i'm glad you mentioned
player mobility is what i was going to
ask you next because i feel like the nfl
has done a lot to try to prevent players
star players
from changing teams in the prime of
their career it becomes difficult it
gets played out in the media gets
stretched out for a long time
the nba's had a lot of success with it i
think it's it's inspired an entire
generation of fans to follow players and
not simply their local teams
do you think that this rogers situation
will be a watershed
moment for the nfl moving forward and
we'll see
uh more fluid player mobility especially
at the quarterback position
i think um i think you used the wrong
word there um he said especially the
quarterback position i think
some degree might be only at the
quarterback position uh
and i mean well you know with rare
exceptions for players that are
considered you know sort of generational
talents at their spots
um i don't think a lot of players can
pull this off i just think it's too hard
to make money in the nfl
and i think too many guys are in the
spot where it's you know
if i can find a way to make money i'm
going to do it any way i can do it
and i don't want to rock the boat
because my earning power is fleeting um
you know the nba and the nfl are
different that way in that nfl players
careers last
longer don't last as long and
um they're going to have a harder time
finding their way to the top of the
market just because
there are more nfl players than there
are nba players they're more replaceable
than nba players are and so
you know i i think you you might see
more players try this and
i i think the i think the
the issue though is that there are very
few players that have the leverage to
pull it off
and you know really the guys who have
the leverage to pull it off are guys who
have a lot of money in their bank
accounts
and the kinds of guys where teams can
look at it and say
that's the kind of guy that i'm willing
to go all in on and give up big time
draft capital to go and get and so
um yeah i mean i i think you could see
more of it the quarterback position
and maybe a couple other spots um where
you know players are valued at that
level but i don't think that this is
going to
change the way business is done in the
nfl for say
your your your just your normal
really solid even pro bowl linebacker or
you're really solid pro bowl guard
i think if there is change that comes
from this i think it's going to be
sort of reserved for the elite of the
elite albert breer joins the show the
monday morning quarterback ben line's in
for rich this is the rich eisen show
devastating news for rams fans out here
in los angeles alberta with the news
coming that
cam akers running back for the rams has
torn his achilles
suffered a torn achilles while training
and he's going to be out for the season
how does this impact the balance of
power not only in
in the nfc west but also in terms of a
real threat to tampa
in the conference because i go through a
lot of these rosters and now i add the
rams to the list albert a lot of
question marks
on these teams with aaron status and in
green bay in question of course i
i don't know who the real challenger is
to tampa in the conference especially
now with acres going down
yeah and i i think i think the way you
want to look at this
um is yes he had a chance to be a really
good player
but if he was going to be what he was
last year
i don't think the drop off from acres to
daryl henderson
is that precipitous where it's going to
change the fate of the season now
if acres were to become what the rams
thought he could become because there's
a ton of untapped potential with acres
he's a high school quarterback he played
behind a really really
shaky offensive line in college so the
whole thing with acres is always
there's going to be more there
eventually he's going to grow as a
tailback
and eventually become more so if you're
talking about what the rams thought
acres could become
which i mean isn't that far off from
what they had a few years ago when todd
growly was in his prime
then yeah i mean like you're losing a
lot but if you're talking about the
player you had last year
i actually think daryl henderson and
whatever they have depth wise can at
least approximate it
where the threat of the running game is
there and that's such a big part of sean
mcday's offenses
the threat of the running game opening
everything else up and the marriage
between the running game
passing game so uh i think it takes away
the superstar potential
that the rams had in the backfield with
acres but if you're talking about just
what was last year i think they can find
a way with what they have in house to
approximate what they had last year
albert often times throughout history
the team that loses the super bowl
struggles to even get back to the
playoffs
i don't think anybody's thinking that
with kansas city heading into this
season
but when you look at the chiefs and as
they regroup and try to make another
postseason run what's the big storyline
you're paying attention to with kansas
city as we're about to get things going
yeah i just think it's you know as much
as anything else
um the changes in the off-season and
revamping the offensive line i mean
that's the big one
you know uh they went through a similar
sort of rebuild before they won the
super bowl on defense
when they added tyron matthew and frank
clark and
really kind of gutted that group and
started over
and they went through some struggles
early on on the defensive side they
eventually got there
but it just took some time right like
for everything to come together
and they've done you know a similar sort
of overhaul on the offensive line this
year
for what happens in the super bowl after
the injury issues they had the tackle
position
and bringing in orlando brown and kyle
long drafting creed humphrey
um you know i i think making all the
changes that they've made up front
bringing
you know um laurent
renee tardif back um you know i think
they
they the hope is that when you get to
december and january
that that group is going to become the
sort of team strength it was a couple
years ago
but i think anybody knows about
offensive line play will tell you that
that can take some time
so you know i think what i'm most
interested in watching with the chiefs
and i know it's a boring answer to this
question
i mean they're good they're still good
in a lot of different spots i think
what's really interesting here is
sort of where that offensive line is in
september and october
and if that could wind up affecting
you know where they are from a seating
perspective when we get to the playoffs
because i do think
they will get to a point later in the
season where they're just fine at those
positions because they did bring in a
lot of good players
senior nfl reporter albert breer kind
enough to join the show
monday morning quarterback we appreciate
the time i hope to meet you in real life
i feel like i've talked to you on the
radio
20 or 30 times over the years perhaps we
can uh hang out face to face
in real life sometime hopefully
hopefully we can do that hey
uh i want to send my well wishes to rich
too get well buddy
uh we all can't wait to have you back on
absolutely
sending a lot of love to rich and we
appreciate you making some time for us
albert thanks so much man
all right thanks ben hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here